and we will also
post the link to the youtube channel
in the um
in the account so in
in the meetup as a comment so you can
also get in it from there
i i'll post it everywhere i i just i
just did it
sorry
and here we go so
with that we can start the recording
also
and we are all ready to start
okay so welcome everyone so this call
this uh talk
is recorded and live on youtube
uh so this is by data berlin meet up may
edition 2021 and today we have one talk
uh by brandon but before i want to
remind you that
pi data is
actually supported by num focus which is
an association to promote uh
open source and data
in sorry
one two so this is uh
supported by num focus and so as part of
non-focus
we have to uh respect their code of
conduct so
the short fashion being be nice with
each other be respectful
uh and everything will be okay if you
have any kind of
uh inappropriate content of
people contacting you please contact me
or ellat who is also
one of the organizer and will take the
necessary activity
action so with that i propose to start
with our first talk after this will be
able to go
into wonder uh which is a platform to
basically have a more
feeling a more better uh
[Music]
more meet up feeling where we'll be
basically on 2d
able to move around and meet other
people and create a small group
uh to talk about whatever you want so
with a beer or something like that
uh but before let's go to the top the
most interesting interesting parts and
today we welcome brandon
who will talk about uh ask your data
finding
information using nlp so
in this talk brendel will show how you
can use
nlp to find the right information
in your task in your in your text
and so brandon is nlp engineer at dipset
and on one side is keeping one finger on
the pulse of nlp research and on the
other
hand trying to apply this cutting edge
model to real problems
and he hold a master degree in
historical linguistics
from cambridge and a conventional
linguistic from stanford university
and is one of the active maintainer of
haystack open source search framework
and brandon this is your tab
hi so uh thanks everyone for joining
today and thank you very much to the
organizers of pi data for having me talk
today
um yeah i really want to talk to you
about uh nlp
and what it can do for anyone who's
working with any kind of text data nlp
keeps on kind of moving forward
there are constantly new models new
techniques new tasks
and this really opens up a lot of
different opportunities for what you can
do with these models
and that's exactly what i want to show
today not just this kind of
task and its isolation but how does
a how does an nlp model uh
actually apply to something you might do
in the real world
um so yeah so
just a bit of background as um as was
mentioned
i am a machine learning engineer at
deepsea
and uh yeah deep set is sitting
somewhere between
the world of research and industry
because from the world of research we
see that there's a real surge
in deep learning based nlp
there's a lot of focus on building
better language models
especially these transformer
architecture models
which have proven to be really really
good at understanding
language and also on question answering
which is this task that i'll talk a
little bit more about
um on the other hand there are a lot of
industry
uh yeah a lot of enterprises a lot of
need in the industry
to get this kind of technology working
for them so
because most large enterprises
are heavily reliant on text and language
to store information
and so really there's a lot of value
that can be brought
from bringing this research uh
and making it applicable to industry and
that's where we sit right in between
here's deep set
very focused on haystack which is our
industrial nlp platform it's fully open
source so you can actually just
go to the github even now and check it
out the focus
of haystack is really to have very
modular pipelines that let you stick
together
different nlp components and i'll talk a
little bit today about
what value we get when we actually
combine together different modules
different tasks different components
what does that actually
give us and the focus pay stack is
really on
being end to end we're not just here to
provide models there are definitely some
other
excellent repositories out there which
are very focused
on the models and they they do an
incredible job
we want to take it one step further to
help you take a step towards
making a production ready system that uh
people will be using
and people will be relying on
uh i also just want to bring up right
now that uh we're actually in a hiring
phase at the moment so
um yeah we're looking for python
engineers and also people in
devops um hopefully you'll get a sense
also
through this talk about what we do with
deep set and uh if this
the challenges that we face sound like
something that's interesting to you
sounds like something that you would
like to get your hands dirty with
then let me know let's have a chat
so um yeah as was already mentioned i am
a machine learning engineer at deep set
uh i had i started off with a real
strong interest in languages doing
classics and linguistics before moving
into computational linguistics which is
where i really got my hands dirty
with this machine learning and nlp
field i'm very mission driven so i
really have this belief
that nlp technology will become
ubiquitous it's really going to be
part of any program that deals with
text and it's going to be we're going to
rely
on it in the way that we rely on
database like sql um
and language technologies will also
significantly change how we interact
with machines i think
i'll talk about this a little bit later
but there are sort of certain
assumptions we already make when we type
in a search into google
and i think as language technologies
improve uh
these sorts of interactions are going to
change over time and i'm actually super
interested
in thinking about what that change might
be like
and uh i also am very much in this world
of open source software
because it's really actually i really
get a lot of sort of excitement out of
seeing this collaboration
between different people who have either
a use or the know-how to
open a pr or just an interest in
learning about
uh about a certain area and so yeah i'm
very committed to
to making sure that like any open source
community that i'm part of
is growing and that everyone's learning
and benefiting from this
collaboration
uh so i want to start off by just giving
a little quick overview
about the state of nlp in 2021
uh let's start with talking about text
which is what nlp is really working on
text is a form of unstructured data
um it needs very different methods to
work with for a computer
means very different methods to work
with as compared to say
numerical or tabular data it makes a
little bit sort of
slippery a little bit trickier to sort
of really categorize
but transformer language models have
been a revelation in the last few years
these are big machine learning models
which
are trained on large amounts of texts
read a lot so that it understands
something about the distribution of
language and how it's used
and they become very very good at
turning text
into vectors so just lists of numbers
which somehow encapsulate some
understanding
of um of what these words
or what these documents mean they
actually become very very useful
because these by doing this by con
converting text into numbers language
models
are able to make different tasks
possible
and a couple of these are for example
question answering summarization
retrieval translation and re-ranking
these are kind of like the really like
core tasks of nlp
and i'm going to be talking about each
one of those
um in this talk and
uh yeah like it's it's really clear that
transformer-based nlp
is going to become a part of every
application we can already see the first
signs of this happening
in the big tech companies already in
google search you'll see that sometimes
when you ask a question
it will actually highlight a specific
answer for you
or that it'll even suggest new answers
or sorry new questions
and propose answers to them so that you
kind of have a suggested sort of next
step
uh on facebook you can already translate
a bunch of comments
and uh this kind of technology has
always been in product recommendations
so it's only gonna become more and more
and
um yeah we want haystack to be
one of the ways in which people can
start incorporating nlp
into whatever program they're building
as i mentioned
it's fully open source uh all the core
nlp tasks are covered
and uh we're very much production
focused
um that's a we i also have integrations
with uh the hugging face model hub
and we know actually like how incredible
this library is
and just these amount of models that it
provides and the ease of use there
it's incredible we have a very close
integration with them so that
you can simply just provide the name of
a model
that's in one of uh in this hugging face
model hub and be able to download it and
use it within haystack
straight away uh and yeah as i mentioned
it's
this is an end-to-end system it's not
just about the models
we really focus a lot on building the
right connectors between the different
components
we put a lot of thought and effort into
making sure
that all the best and all the most
efficient storage options
are there for you and we have just a lot
of different quality of life features
that make working with uh with nlp
models that bit easier
okay so i want to just start off by
going through a couple of different
tasks
one of some of these core nlp tasks
that we've seen become really really
possible with
transformer based language models and
the real
flagship of this is question answering
and question answering works like this
you can see it on the left
uh you start off with a question maybe
you're asking
what is berlin you have a document
which contains the answer in it
somewhere and then you give these this
pair to one of these question answering
models
and a good model should be able to
highlight for you
the section of text that answers this
question
uh for example yeah here the answer is
the largest city of germany which you
can see
in the document the most common approach
to this
right now is to use what we call a
reader model
this is a language model that's been
adapted to question answering and what
it essentially does
is that it identifies the start and the
end of the span of text that forms the
answer
to turn a language model into a reader
model do you want to train it
on question answer pairs so pairs like
what you see here
on the left and the squad data set um
is the default question answering data
set um
it's not only one of the really early
ones uh but it also has a
it's very sizable one and we've actually
also found
that models that are trained on this
actually generalized quite nicely to
things that we might not have expected
at first squad is actually
uh based on wikipedia articles but we
found this to actually be very capable
of uh like models trained on squad are
very capable of working
on data sets that are not wikipedia that
are uh
earnings calls for examples or internal
documents
or um yeah it's actually really quite
impressive or even just out of domain on
other topics and actually we'll see that
in the demo in just a second
and uh why now what made question
answering suddenly such a hot topic
well the short answer to this is
transformers
before transformers question answering
we never really got really good
performance there uh with the advent of
burt
we saw a huge spike in the performance
especially on the squad data set
and it's been gradually improving since
such that actually the best
question answering models will
outperform a human
on squad uh there's a big
momentum in research as well right now
to get uh
different types of data sets out there
data sets that are perhaps more
challenging
than the squad data sets that perhaps
tackle things like yes no
questions uh which are not the case in
squad
and also uh data sets that tackle
different languages
we actually recently created a german
question answering data set and train
some models off of that
and now we have models that are capable
of doing question answering
on german data um
and yeah we've also found that like
these models uh just have a lot of value
in them because
they're actually just very applicable to
some very real
business problems and because of this
we've like yeah we've really put a lot
of effort to understanding how question
answering systems work
and uh we think that actually we'd
actually be really excited for other
people to try these models out and see
if it works
and helps them in trying to find answers
to their questions
so at this point i want to switch over
to a demo just to give you a sense
of um what these systems do
so i'm going to go over there right now
and i just want to make sure that
everyone can see this i wonder if
someone can
give me a bit of confirmation comments
or thumbs up
yes awesome excellent excellent
um so yeah right here we have a
streamlight ui that's plugged into
a haystack based system but it's a
question answering system
um and uh yeah we've
indexed the harry potter fandom
wiki pages and we now have the system
where we can actually just
ask it questions and see how the model
interprets question and answer
so we can also start off with asking
something like
what is the patronus of
harry let's see how that goes
um i did actually a little earlier um
and you can see here the the sections
which the model
is highlighting has the answer and we've
got deer
a stag uh we've got actually another
question
sorry another answer which isn't quite
the same but actually in some ways like
answers this too like the question is
what is the patronus of harry probably
asking specifically
what is patronus what is harry's
patronus but it can also
be interpreted as what is a patronus
generally
and here we have a magical manifestation
of goodwill
and happiness um
how does fred please
let's try that one
um here we get
a answer which sort of the top answer is
close
sort of gets there not quite there uh
but it does at least highlight when
fred weasley dies uh the better answers
actually come a little bit lower but
here we have
um the model being able to recognize
that yeah that fred was killed in an
explosion outside the room of
requirement by augustus rookwood and you
can see that
it's not highlighting just single
entities
or single names it's actually very
capable of highlighting a full phrase
sentence some models even a paragraph
to answer some rather open-ended
questions
and uh to try one last one what
house is mine
um yeah and you can hear see
uh some conflicting answers here but you
can see also yeah granger's houses
in rangers home heathgate hampstead um
which is technically correct but not
quite i guess
the same um it's correct it's the
correct answer it is it's house that
hermione
lives in um but also yeah the proper
answer that
most people are probably looking for is
further down
in gryffindor uh it's also tries to
yeah also highlights hogwarts times but
yeah you can see now that like
this is a very open-ended kind of uh
question
that you can ask and um it's quite a
challenging task
uh but these models have really shown a
lot of capabilities to
answer questions from yeah everything
from harry potter to financial documents
to legal questions
and we really see that uh there are
going to be a lot of people out there
who really want to get their hands dirty
with these kinds of models
so going back to my slides
uh yeah it's it's a really flexible kind
of task
and what we've seen here is uh it's very
useful in this case
that we know as a knowledge based search
so
you want to ask a question to a textual
knowledge base
and you want to return sections of text
as answers and it's really useful
for for example documentation or the or
unorganized collections of texts and
um in an enterprise or just in your you
know
organization we've also seen that
it's been very useful for some other
people who are interested in the idea of
uh information extraction
so you can use this on incoming streams
of documents which have very similar
content
for each one of these documents you
might be interested in asking
just the same set of questions for each
one because they
have similar content you're trying to
extract and we've seen this work really
well for
patents where you might be always asking
what is unique about this patent or what
is uh who is bringing forth this patent
and also in legal documents yeah there's
a lot of potential there for sure
and i want to flag up just one more use
case which is actually
a little bit more experimental but i
think it shows just kind of how cool
this task is
which is what we're referring to is zero
shot usages
and this ties a little bit into the
research
of like prompt engineering the question
the
the task here is like how do you ask the
right question to get the most out of
this model
and we've experimented and actually seen
some really nice results
when we've tried to use this question
answering style for something like
named entity recognition uh in typical
named entity recognition you would have
to have a training data set and say
label certain companies for being
electric vehicle manufacturers something
like that
but using question answering we can
actually do this in a very zero-shot way
we don't actually have to train
on these labels we don't need these
labels in the first place we can
actually just ask something like
which company manufactures electric
vehicles
and we've seen that the model is
actually very capable a lot of the time
to highlight as the answer the entities
that we're looking for
we also see this uh as
a way of substituting entity relation
you can ask a question like who are the
partners of bmw and the model will try
its best
to answer that it's not always going to
give you
an entity the way that you expect from
named entity recognition sometimes you
get
more general um a more general phrase
something like you know
it's just standard partners or other
companies in the automotive industry
but that's then also where you can come
back in with an ner system
and really just extract exactly
the name that you want when you need
so that was question answering i want to
go on
and talk a little bit about document
retrieval which is usually more spoken
of in the realm of
information extraction but actually has
a lot of importance
also here also here in nlp
uh so it works something like this the
user makes a query
and we have a query up here like what
kind of dog breeds are there
and the system is tasked with returning
relevant documents
so you pass this query into a retriever
and the retriever
will bring back relevant documents as
you can see down the bottom there
there are quite a lot of different
approaches to document retrieval there
are key based uh keyword based
approaches
like tf idf and bm25 this has
been these methods have been really
effective for quite a long time
and i think that a lot of you probably
are very aware of these techniques
they're very fast they're lightweight
and they're effective
but i do have to flag up that it's a bag
of words approach
so it really works by matching keywords
between this query
and the documents that you're looking in
and
this works for many many tasks it
works in many many settings but it falls
short because sentences aren't just a
bag of words sentences have a syntax
and you need a little bit of sensitivity
to sort of words being
objects or subjects or just how
the the sentence is phrased to really
get the best answers
and this is what the latest transformer
based approaches can offer
and these transformer-based approaches
i'm talking about are things like dense
passage retrieval
dpr um or sentence transformers
these are uh yeah full machine learning
models
uh which are much more syntax sensitive
they actually kind of read through the
sentence
and try to understand the relations
between words but at the same time they
require a lot more compute
power to index and to query
how these actually function is that if
you have a set of documents that you
want to index
it will read through all of these you
pass all of these through a transformer
model one of your machine learning
models
and it turns these documents into
vectors
and you store these vectors and come
query time
you only have to encode the query into a
vector you turn that into a vector
and then you do a comparison between the
query vector and all these
vectors that you have stored in your
document store to find
which is the most similar or which is
the most relevant
and so in this transformer based
approach in this new kind of machine
learning
based style it's actually really
important to have
the right document store if you want to
optimize for performance
elasticsearch and sql are capable of
working with these styles
but the issue is that they're not really
optimized for vector similarity
comparisons and there's a whole new
generation of document stores coming up
which are much more suited to this kind
of task so there's milvis
there's vice and there's wevier which
are all much more geared towards making
sure that these vector similarity
comparisons
are quick
uh i want to move on to the next task
which is the task of
summarization i think intuitively uh
everyone here probably knows what
summarization
is you might put in a larger piece of
text in this case here we have
a snippet from a news article we pass it
to a summarizer
and we want to summarize that so that we
get something that might be used as
a title or a tagline or an abstract or
something like that
but that captures kind of the most
important information
um all i have to say here is that yeah
people have been working on
transformer-based summarization models
and they've proven to actually
be really really effective and really
performant
the style that these transform based
summarization
models uses is called abstractive
summarization
rather than extractive summarization the
difference is that in
extractive summarization you basically
copy paste
sections of the original text and stick
them together
again to form your summary at the end
abstractive summarization works
differently from that
it reads in the text that it needs to
summarize it remembers it a bit
and then it generates word by word an
answer so actually
the words that you find in your summary
might not even
uh occur in the text that you're
summarizing
that's kind of beautiful it's much more
flexible than how it phrases things
to give you a sense of just how good
these models are google released the
pegasus model a little while back which
is one of the
leading summarization models and they
reported in their blog that human raters
do not consistently prefer the human
summaries to those from their model
which is really quite impressive when
you think about it and they even ran
some experiments to really kind of poke
to see what capabilities these models
have and these models are actually
showing some ability to count if it says
uh if it lists out three ships it will
say
and these three ships and if it lists
out four i'll
refer to them as being four ships and so
on uh that's actually a really cool
feature of these models
and that's really nice behavior to know
and
we can only it's really interesting to
probe this and to see how much we can
develop this more and how far it can go
uh so that's a really nice sign and just
more proof these yeah summarization
models are really
quite impressive it's quite impressive
i'm going to highlight two more tasks
which i think
are quite interesting uh one being
translation once again i think that's
quite clear to everyone how this works
but transfer uh translation
models uh that are built on transformers
are working really really well and
there's a lot
of interest and a lot of need for these
kinds of models there are a lot of
open source models that are available
now and on the hugging phase mod hub
if you search for translation models it
returns something like
1400 models there's really a lot out
there
and we see just in a lot of the programs
that we use just how useful it can be
to have some sort of translation module
and it's interesting to see that yeah
in in amazon product descriptions in
facebook
uh comments and in on google
translation is just embedded in and
ready there to to adapt to your language
and so yeah it's really it's really cool
to see that there are this many open
source models for translation
and that if you are building a system
that is working with text
you too can try to embed uh a
translation module into whatever you're
working with
the other thing that i want to talk
about here is re-rank so i talked a
little bit about retrieval
and um yeah retrieval is basically
you that you have a large set of
documents and you want to just return
only the ones that are most relevant and
these
retrieval models are really optimized to
work on very very
big document stores it has to like in a
lot of systems we're talking about in
the millions of documents
and you want a retriever that is able to
at least very briefly scan over all of
these
and kick out the ones which are not uh
that are not relevant to your query
but this means that you sacrifice a
little bit of performance and so
re-rankers come in and try to improve
what
the retriever does what it essentially
does is it
does a closer reading of the subset
of documents that the retriever returns
because they're not always very well
ordered
and its job is to push the most relevant
documents
to the very top and this is really
important for systems because
it allows for a certain degree of
flexibility and efficiency and this is a
theme we're going to see a little bit
more
as i talk about how we combine models
using the right model
at different scales allows you to build
systems that do really
smart things in really fast ways
sometimes you don't need
your full machinery to be run on your
million documents
you want to maybe quickly and smartly
filter out some things before passing it
on
to the smarter models which take a
little bit longer
that's how you're going to optimize the
best performance as you scale up
so yeah i really want to focus here on
talking about what we can
gain when we mix and match these
different
tasks that i've just been talking about
and i hope that some of this has already
maybe kind of come to your mind as i've
been talking about it
because i think there are some very
clear synergies there so
one of them that we that i'll be talking
about is open domain question answering
which is composed of a retriever model
plus the reader model from question
answering
um the idea here is that reader models
are really really powerful
but we might need something to do that
first filter step first
and i'll talk a little bit more about
this in a bit um but some other
possibilities here we could talk about
yeah like the
the retriever being passing on documents
to a re-ranker so the best documents are
at the top
and then we can also summarize these
documents so that
for each query your end user doesn't
have to read through
10 full documents instead they can read
just
10 summaries 10 sentences to get a sense
of which one of these might actually be
most relevant
to what they need and we've also been
experimenting a little bit with the idea
of using translation as a wrapper for
these systems
so maybe you want to have a question
answering
question answering system in uh less
supported language i don't know
let's say let's say uyga for example and
maybe you are
ask a question in wiga and you use a
translator to translate this question
into an english question
you perform question answering in
english
and then you re-translate it at the end
the answer in the end
back into uyghur that's all possible
with these models
and this is really what we've been
focusing on with haystack and especially
our pipelines class this is really one
of our
our favorite features of uh of haystack
and where we really think
that we can really help people who are
trying to build
effective systems with a haystack
pipeline
you can define combinations of indexing
of storage and of nlp components you can
easily
modify and recombine and switch out
parts
the full configuration can be saved to a
yaml file and it can be loaded from
there
and that's exactly what you want what
that's what you see on the right there
this is all the text you need in a yaml
file
in order to save and load a question
answering model
um yeah and if you do want to get
started on this
uh it's we have a tutorial ready for you
so you can actually already start
playing around with it
so i'd highly encourage you to check it
out
so the task that we've really been
really excited about and really
interested in is
question answering at scale um
so i've spoken already about question
answering and
these reader models which are really
really good at what they do but they do
have certain limitations and they're
challenged in certain ways
so for one uh there's a limited input
length that can be passed on to a reader
model
and this means that it's you have to do
something a little bit smart in order to
pass in bigger documents also
readers are computationally quite
expensive
and they take quite a bit of time to run
and on top of that
even if you are doing um question
answering and splitting up
long documents into shorter passages
your reader model is going to make a
prediction on each one of these split
documents and you need to figure out how
to pick
the best answer out of all these
candidate answers
uh and to solve some of these problems
uh we have this
retriever reader set up and this is
something that's been
been very effective and it's an idea
that comes a bit from
information retrieval um but this is
really where we kind of see this
intersection of these two fields of ins
of information retrieval and nlp really
bringing out something really really
cool
so this retriever reader pipeline is
really all about this
efficiency when it comes to large
collections of text i was talking about
the retriever acts as your first stage
as a lightweight filter
so that we just get the most important
documents we can
kick out the majority and then we pass
these on to a reader which does a slower
reading of these candidate documents
to finally give us the answer that we
need
um to give a sense of sort of what sort
of a speed up you can expect with
this kind of technology we did an
experiment where we had about
seven and a half thousand documents from
the natural questions development set
we're using a roberta based model and a
tesla v100
if you run a reader on your full set of
documents
on just for one query we're talking
about like over three hours for a query
which is absolutely way too much
but if you can also put a retriever into
this pipeline and do that first
filtration step
we can actually reduce this time down to
something like
0.5 to 2 seconds without a very
significant hit to the performance
and yeah you can see just on the right
there what this flow looks like
and tried to show a little bit with the
arrows there just sort of this idea
of starting out with lots of documents
and passing them all onto the retriever
filtering
getting less giving a manageable amount
to the reader before
coming out with a small set of candidate
answers
so just give a sense of how we might
build this in haystack code
i showed you kind of a yaml
configuration before this can also be
done
in the pure python code this is sort of
what it looks like in haystack
uh it can be done in quite a few lines
but i hope that you can also see here
that the abstractions that we pick here
make some sense and that are intuitive
to use that you might be encouraged to
use them
uh with haystack we only need to
initialize a couple
of objects or a couple of core objects
which are the top three here we have the
document store and in this case we're
initializing an elastic search document
store this is where obviously we're
going to be
indexing our documents
we also want to initialize the retriever
in this case
we have an elastic search retriever
which uses the bm25 algorithm that's
built into elasticsearch
and we connect this up to the document
store through the argument
and then we want to also initialize a
reader model
and here we're using a farm-based reader
farm is our other open source
software where we build quest uh various
transfer learning pipelines
uh question answering readers being one
of them so here we initialize the farm
reader
and here you can see that we can pass in
just the name of the model and this is
one of the names
that refers to a model in the hugging
face
model hub or one that you've saved
locally but if you're yeah you're trying
to use something from the
hugging face model hub maybe someone's
just trained a new robot model
all you have to do is type in the name
into there and it will automatically
download it
from the hub and you can start using it
in haystack in your open domain qa
pipeline
this next line the pipe is what connects
everything together
here you want to pass in the reader and
retriever so that they're all
connected up together and then we can
start
running our queries and here you can see
we run simply pipe.run
and we type in our query here we're
asking who is the father of arya stock
and then we're going to return a
prediction which we want to print out
and this prediction might look something
like this
so we're being returned both the answer
string
and in this case in the top cases we get
the right answer eddard or ned
and also some metadata around that
there's a lot more metadata that can be
returned here but we're taking a much
more minimal
approach here and you just see where
this answer is occurring the context
around this answer span so that you can
read and check to make sure that
this is really the answer that you're
looking for
yeah so i've been talking a little bit
here about
this idea of pipelines and how crucial
that is to
combining different components and how
haystack enables us
to come up with our own combinations
and yeah improve systems optimize them
see what we can build i think it's uh
we think of them as sort of like lego
blocks you can really they have all the
connects they need but you can
if you have the blocks you connect them
as you like and see how it works
so i'm going to give you just a couple
of examples of what you might want to do
so for example you might have an
interest
in ensembling retrievers as i spoke
about in the earlier slide
different retrievers have different
strengths and weaknesses
keyword-based retrievers are very quick
and efficient but they don't really
understand syntax so much uh the dense
retrievers the ones which are based on
transformers
are really really powerful but they take
longer to run and sometimes um
[Music]
and they're actually primed very much to
expect uh queries that are
a full sentence that are like they're a
phrase like a question
and so yeah there are strengths and
weaknesses to both and maybe let's try
to use both here so what we could do
is initialize this kind of a pipeline
and when we run a query
the query will be sent to both the
keyword retriever
and the dance retriever and each one of
these
will pick out its set of candidate
documents
and all these documents will then be
passed on to the reader
and then we once again get our answer at
the end of it
and the beauty of this is that you don't
have to pick like
there might have been a question that
could have very easily
been answered by the keyword retriever
but perhaps
or at least maybe there was a question
that the dance retriever was very good
at finding documents for
but the keyword retrieval was not so
good at and in this situation
both these retrievers are going to pass
on documents and it's
not going to slip through the gap like
this query is not going to slip through
the gaps of your system
this is just one possibility there's
kind of another approach to this kind of
idea which we refer to
as query routing through classification
and how this works is that we add a
component
in before the retrievers known as the
query classifier
so as i said the keyword retriever is
very good at dealing with
um with keyword-based searches it's the
style of search where you just type in
just keywords it might just be dog
breeds rather than
what kind of dog breeds are there in
antarctica or something like that
um and
yeah so you you might have those kind of
queries but you might also have queries
that are
full for like a full question and it's
you can define a node and like and here
again you can define this query
classifier to read the query
and to tell you whether you're dealing
with a query that's more like this
keywords based style or more a full
sentence kind of query
and then this query classifier is able
to root this query
so that it engages only one of the two
retrievers
and gets documents from those retrievers
and then passes it on to the reader to
get the answers so you can see that
if the system thinks that you're dealing
with just a keyword-based query and
thinks there's not as much value
um working with the dense retriever it
can pass
directly to the keyword retriever we can
run a much leaner
pipeline and get a much quicker like
much more quickly get to an answer at
the end of all this
and this is only one of the style of
routing that we could imagine
i've talked to here about this keyword
versus question style
but maybe you have differently trained
retrievers maybe you have very
domain specific retrievers and you want
to
classify your query on whether it's
about medical text
or whether it's about legal text and
depending on that
that might determine which retriever you
want
to use and so that's also possible here
and also
maybe there are certain expectations for
what a query should look like
and if it's really out of the range of
expectations you might want to route to
some kind of fallback option that's all
possible with these pipelines
and this sort of flexibility and um yeah
we don't think that there's like one
nlp model to do all things so there are
lots of experiments in that sort of
realm
um but we actually really see that
there's a lot of value in having these
models
in combining these models that are each
really specialized at one task
um and there's actually certain
optimization benefits to this
uh which we will talk about a little bit
later down the line
but yeah i just want to mention once
again another
a couple other combinations i've already
kind of touched on a couple of these so
we have this idea of like enhanced
retrieval we could
uh rank the results from the retriever
uh using the re-ranker we can summarize
each document and pass on just a summary
to the user so it's a read
like a readable amount we could wrap a
pipeline in a translator as i said we
can
translate a request into
a target language perform our task in
that target language
and translate the answer back into the
source language
or something that we played around a
little bit with is this idea of doing
knowledge craft
enhanced question answering so
as well as having this retriever and
document store combination
you could also have parallel to that a
knowledge graph
and a knowledge graph retriever so when
a query comes in
you can have a model which will
translate
this this natural language query
into a sparkle query the sparkle query
is used by the retriever to um to query
into the knowledge graph
your return and answer um what we found
that actually is that like it's actually
there's quite some value to have this
working in parallel to a question
answering system
so you get one answer from your
knowledge graph and one answer from your
question answering system
and once again we have this like ability
to have models
that can um i can fill in the gaps and
weaknesses of each other
that's kind of the beauty of it
and uh yeah so this is all this is all
really possible with haystack and we
we're really focusing on making sure
that you can build this full pipeline
and we have all the document stores to
make sure that your system runs quickly
we have all the data connections that
you might need to make this work nicely
you can read in files from text or pdf
or docx or markdown
there's a web scraper as well to turn
your website
into text and we uh we provide all the
pre-processing
elements you might need to split long
documents or to clean your text
and uh yeah our focus here is also on
like ease of integration with haystack
to make sure
that haystack will connect to your
program so we have a rest api
uh so that you can very easily call
you can make calls to the system that
you built and we also have support for
docker containers so that it's very easy
to deploy these systems
as i mentioned we have a lot of we've
focused a lot on qa tools
and um yeah you can we have these tools
such as our qa annotation tools which we
use for
our own german question answering data
set
to create that and also for various
industry product projects
and you can also train a lot of the
models that are contained in haystack
and yeah we're we're constantly adding
more support for the latest technology
maybe some of you
have heard about like the deberta model
of big bird
we've eat knowledge graphs we are
keeping up with whatever we see as being
meaningful technology that we can
incorporate in a user-friendly way
and um this is all really this is all
just
valuable because we can combine together
all these different components that's
why
we have so many different models and
different components
and yeah i just want to talk for a
minute about optimizations which is that
um
yeah haystack the way that it's designed
is also done in a way
to keep search uh in the milliseconds
because we know that this is
runtime is very crucial to the user
experience and we're also very
interested
in scaling these systems so that they
run route
run well when being used in an
enterprise setting so
uh we have these document stores which
are um
in the millions of documents we're going
to make sure that our models run
in this sort of scale we do a lot um on
working on managing and optimizing cloud
infrastructure
we are constantly benchmarking the
performance of every component that we
incorporate
and we also have been working on
haystack hub
which is the fully managed version um
like a fully managed system
um that has yeah that is going to be
speedy and
much easier like much more codeless to
work with
and uh just one kind of thing on the
roadmap that i really want to highlight
is the potential um is is is the
integration of ray into what we're
it's what we're creating so i've talked
a lot about this kind of pipelining
style where we can have nodes
of processing uh there's a big value of
having this is that we can actually
imagine that each one of these nodes
could be deployed
to a different server and when we have
this we have a very adaptable
uh distributed system where we can scale
the compute that we need
in each step of our pipeline and ray
is the as an open source um
framework that allows for this kind of
fast and simple
distributed computing and we're actually
really really excited
to get this working for our pipelines we
see a lot of synergy there
and we see that uh this is going to be a
really big step forward
so um that's most of the content that i
want to talk about today but i just want
to wrap up before i finish
by uh talking a little bit about why
nlp is really important and why it's
worth getting started on it today
so we really see actually like beyond
these small tasks these are the small
building blocks towards a much
bigger possibility using nlp and we see
that language is actually going to
become
the interface to all kinds of data it's
already actually possible to ask
questions onto table data
there's this tapus model that has come
out uh where it's possible to do this
and we also see the link between text
data and image data
is closer than ever there's this really
cool project called dali
you can actually see an example on the
on the right there it's quite
fun actually if you type in a prompt
like an armchair in the shape of an
avocado
it will actually generate images of
armchairs in the shape of an avocado
it's crazy but it's super cool and
yeah just only highlighting how text is
going to be closer to every other kind
of medium
nlp is also going to fundamentally
impact how we interact with computers
we have a lot of preconceptions about
how we use search we've really been
doing a lot of keyword based search
thanks to google and that kind of
control f
technology that we generally rely on but
we can see this changing where there's
going to be a lot of value when you can
actually ask a full sentence
so that you can differentiate between
how do i travel from germany to
to france as compared to how do i travel
from france to germany
and this is really going to allow for
much more support for different
languages
when nlp models and translation models
are more ubiquitous
and i think this is the most important
point here uh we we believe that every
tech stack every enterprise tech stack
is going to have a semantic layer
there is so much to be gained by storing
your text data in some sort of semantic
layer so that you can do something much
more smart with your text so that you
can make it
more easily searchable so you can easily
summarize
streams of information that are coming
in and that you can really interact with
it in a way that feels much more natural
and intuitive to humans
so the there's so much potential there
there's such a future here for nlp
and um if if this is something that's
got you excited
uh we want you to try out haystack we
want you to get your hands dirty
and see what's possible there already um
and also if any of these problems any of
these projects sound interesting to you
any of this
scaling and creation of these sort of
tools are interesting to you i want to
say once more
that we're hiring and we're looking for
a python developer or someone into
devops
we hope that you could like maybe that
you also feel a bit of this excitement
we have for building this really cool
nlp future coming up
um so yeah on that note i just want to
thank everyone for
attending today and uh if you have any
questions please feel free to ask me now
here are some links here and thanks so
much for listening
thank you very much brandon you can keep
this on the screen for a minute more
uh they want to take over or should i
ask a few questions that came in in the
youtube in the chat
i'm happy to take questions yeah let me
let me ask a few questions
so um one uh question that came up is
what's the most
interesting in the chat what's the most
interesting use case that you've seen
that's built from haystack
yeah um it's definitely this knowledge
graph
um it was quite experimental
but it was we actually saw quite some
value out of it so the knowledge graph
when you query into knowledge graphs
there are certain things that it has
this natural advantage of doing
it's very good at dealing with questions
which sort of
asks sort of uh is there a relation
between a and b
um and you know you can simply just
query into the graph and see whether
there is a link there or not
the other thing that it's very good at
is counting operations and arithmetic
operations you might ask
how many children does harry have
and in the question answering based on
text style
um you really rely on what sort of text
there is out there and how it's phrased
and it might actually list them out but
it's a matter of
does the question answering model
actually count and not all models right
now are capable of doing that
but with the knowledge graph we can
actually cover that weakness
and in a knowledge graph it will simply
be count the number of
links in this knowledge graph that are
relation
children tied to harry um
so yeah that was actually a really cool
project to work on and we're really
really happy with that and
this knowledge graph is actually
incorporated into haystack as well so if
you do want to check it out
um i'd encourage you to have a look
there
and can you is it on the github
already yeah in github we already have
um we have these components um
yeah while you're answering the question
i'll put in the link in the in the chat
um so next question comes from youtube
from contemnato he asks
um oh they ask uh can they
can they do they'll send correctly that
you can create
elastic search indexes from uh for
example
json data via hashtag
uh so an elasticsearch instance uh
for json data did you say yes the
question reads
uh or maybe maybe it's something can i
can they create elasticsearch indexes
from json data so you can you put
process
can you process data via hashtag to
create elasticsearch indices
yes uh we can so um in haystack
the fundamental unit that we're talking
about is something known as a document
document is just collecting um is a it's
just a block
of text and so if you're jason um
if there is a major text field in your
json then you will want to put it in as
document
but on top of this to reflect a bit of
the structure of the json
there's also support for adding in
metadata that's tied to this document
so whatever other fields maybe you have
a field about the author or the source
or the date
you can populate the metadata field in
haystack for this document
and you can then index all of this into
the elasticsearch instance
we found that this is actually really
really useful because it allows us to do
some filtering later on maybe you only
want to ask on a slice of your data
or maybe yeah this metadata is just
generally really really useful and we
have support for that and that's
that's how i would see jason being
incorporated there
perfect thank you and uh oh i want to
remind everyone that we're still open
for questions so if you have any
questions drop them
in a chat and we'll bring them up um so
irina asks
basically how much uh overhead is it
for the machine learning person or
whether is the developing
the machine learning model to how much
how much hands-on work is it to create a
model specifically she
asks um how much of this process tends
to be fully learned or trained
and how much requires plenty of
intermediate steps to tweak the output
of each step
to help the following steps so in the
kind of in the pipe
of uh that is created by uh by a
haystack
how much of this do you need to kind of
fiddle the pipes and optimize
versus just walks out of the box yeah um
so i want to start off by saying that um
while we have done some like
model training and to create question
answering models
especially um there are so many models
out there which do their tasks really
really well so for example
um yeah like like there are other
question answering models out there
they're translation models
uh that's what they're trained on and
that's where they're evaluated on their
sort of individual
level um
and so uh yeah that's what they're
really optimized for
i can definitely see we definitely do a
lot of sort of tweaking on our end to
once we've built a system once we like
defined the structure of it
we will run lots of queries and look to
see
what the answers are like and there is
definitely some tweaking to be done
there
um but it's not like you have to retrain
these models
the tweaking that i'm talking about is
sort of getting the parameters right
so that your retriever is taking
uh is not passing on too many documents
to your reader and overloading it
or using the right kind of model or it's
this sort of optimization
um and also yeah splitting documents so
that they're not too long
these sorts of optimizations are the
sorts of things which will uh
give you a fast running and effective
model
and this is the kind of overhead that
that comes with defining these custom
pipelines
but it's definitely definitely
significantly less than say
um tweaking like then then having to
train a model from scratch doing this
kind of
um doing this like learnt style this
supervised style of training
i hope that answers the question
uh i sure hope so if not uh please post
a follow-up in the comments
yeah absolutely yeah um uh
so lillian asks are there any existing
use cases for reading legal documents
sorry any existing use cases for reading
legal documents
yeah yeah yeah definitely then this is
one of the areas of like where there's a
lot of interest
um basically what you want to do is get
um yeah legal texts you want to index
them into a document store
and then run this classic retriever
reader pipeline
and um i've seen this uh
yeah it's really that it really depends
on what you want to do on the legal
front i know there are projects where
they want to um look a little bit more
into sort of the interrelations between
documents
uh that's really kind of the next step
forward but if you want to be able to
just ask questions
and highlight sections of text which
answer that
in legal documents this is exactly what
haystack
is is strong at so i'd really encourage
anyone who's working in that domain to
give it a shot
great yeah go ahead yeah i will i i've
got also some question
uh one is more precision uh so is there
a difference between keyword retriever
and sparse retriever
in slides 17 uh that was uh yeah uh the
there are synonyms in the way that we
refer to them so um sparse retrieval to
us
is um i'm just going to slice it
yeah uh sparse retrieval this kind of
sparse dense
uh distinction is about sort of the
the vectors that are created so in tf
idf what is actual and
bm25 what's actually created is like a
very very sparse vector it's very long
has lots of zeros in it and only a
couple of ones or small numbers in there
whereas in dense retrieval when you put
text through a model
you end up with a fixed size vector of
say uh
700 of 700 dimensions
and each one of those dimensions has a
number in there and
uh very few of these will be zero or
very few of these will
be meaning it's much more dense
representation um
so yeah keyword is equal to sparse when
it comes to retrievers dense
is the transformer based encoding
embedding style
yeah great
um a general question then um do you
do you do research at dip set and
publish paper in workshops and
conferences
yeah we have um so uh the most recent
research that's actually that we've done
is this german question answering data
set so
we created the data set assessed how
well it was being annotated uh created
some models and compared the performance
there
to other approaches like zero shot
question answering um the bottom line
here what we've like
we'd already done some research into the
field a little bit before
and what we found really was that hand
annotated data is always better than any
kind of
synthetically generated data there are
techniques where you like for example
take
english squad and translate it all into
another language
this data is nice but it doesn't give
you
the same level of performance so we
wanted to do it right there
and we created this data set it also
enabled us to create a
dense passage retrieval data set and
with these two we created
um yeah the data sets and the models to
create
open domain question answering in german
uh
this is from timo muller and maltepeach
and julian risch i really encourage you
guys to check it out
if you look up german quad uh and deep
set
you'll you'll almost certainly find it
and yeah we've always done a little bit
um some years ago i
worked on german bert which is uh one of
the first
german language language models um and
also i
more recently submitted submitted well
actually
gave the talk in december um about
german electra
which is the kind of update to that the
more performant version
of the german book
thanks quite a lot of things
uh another question uh have you looked
at using hashtag pipeline outside of qa
for example filtering document based on
entity linking
um so let me just let me just have a
quick read of this
uh it's from we
[Music]
yeah um our focus right now is yeah
um our focus really now is on question
answering
um we think that this is kind of the
most promising and like just in terms of
real-life use cases we found this to be
the most flexible the one
which you can get started with the most
quickly um
i said like any eyes it's a super useful
task and it's been around for a long
time and it's really great
uh one of the limitations is that
everyone usually has a very different
sort of ner task
and so it if you do want something a
little bit custom it becomes
a little bit it takes a lot more effort
to get that system running
which is why currently there isn't this
uh
first-class support for ner in haystack
but with the pipelines you can define
nodes so like you can define a create
classifier you can create a reader
you can define a node which would be any
r
so you simply feed your data into this
node
and then you might use an nr system from
say
from farm or from hugging face
transformers
do any r and rejoin it back with data
and
um yeah so there's definitely like the
space in a haystack
to incorporate ner into this pipeline
um it just hasn't been a first-class
citizen for us yet
okay um
okay we have uh another question
so is there any future scope for
digital automation of annotation process
at haystack during fine tuning of
pre-trained model
uh language model for qa purpose
yeah um so it's been like we've learned
a lot about um the annotation process
and a lot of this also comes from
um other research out there um and there
are
annotation is is very costly it's very
time consuming
and um yeah
it's it's a tough task but there's
really nothing that beats it at the
moment
and so what we really look a lot into is
ways to
make this process more efficient
and um bring better performance to our
models quicker
so there are quite a few concepts which
actually have been really really
interesting to us which we've
drawn some inspiration from one of them
is this idea
of question rephrasing when an annotator
has been
writing questions for a whole day
they often will start using the same
structures over and over again
and it's hard to break out of that
pattern sometimes so one of the
approaches you can have is to get get
your annotators to create the first set
of questions
but then come back later and say hey
let's have the same question but let's
word it in a different way let's try to
trick the model a bit let's try to
make it a little bit tougher for the
model and have the model
need to be a little bit more flexible um
this idea of sort of like challenging
the model more
has also been tapped into a lot in other
research where they
have sort of humans in the loop when it
comes to annotating
so the idea in that is that you have a
human annotator
you create a question answer pair and
you pass it to an already trained
question answering model and then it
performs a prediction
and so the model will either
get it right in which case this question
uh which was created by the human is too
easy
and then we'll prompt the user to create
a harder question
or the model will get it wrong and we
know ah okay this is actually a sample
that the model can learn from and then
this sample will put into like a hard
set
which is uh stuff that really trips
existing trained models
so yeah these are both ways to make it
more efficient there's a million ways
out there
um but definitely there's there's a lot
if anyone is going into this process of
trying to annotate things
i would definitely encourage reading up
a little bit about this
asking us if you want some tips about
how to make this process
uh efficient and effective
thank you so uh two final questions
and uh then we'll go for the post uh
post meetup links that in wonder which
in the link that i posted in the chat
um so first question uh contaminator uh
from youtube asks um how
can you imagine how do you imagine
domain specific customizations of
retrievers
so they're a social scientist with some
basic python np skills
which is exactly i think more or less
your your target audience like you don't
need to know that much
and how do you think about what kind of
uh
domain specific retrievals you you can
have
yeah um so when we yes so retrievers are
customizable
especially when we're talking about
dense retrievers
and um when you have like a question
answering
data set apart from being a question
answering data set it's also
indirectly a retrieval data set
basically you have
you put all the all the documents in
this data set
uh into a document store and you ask a
question
and wherever the answer appears you can
say hey that's a relevant document to
this question
so ultimately this is the kind of data
that you need
to train a dense passage retrieval model
literally just a query pointing to a
document
that contains an answer to your query or
at least is relevant um one
type of domain adaptation is like
language adaptation
which uh in which case yeah we had this
german question answering data set
and we trained it on these pairs but uh
yeah maybe you want to start training on
something that's more specific
maybe you want to talk about legal data
maybe you want to talk about medical
data
then you would have to go through this
process you would
have to create these pairs of here's a
query
and here is a document that is relevant
to it
and this is a document that exists in
this collection of documents
if you have annotations in the range of
like you'll need
annotations in the range of about a
couple thousand but at that point
you will be able to build a system that
uh yeah really understands your domain
and is specialized for retrieving
documents
um on whatever this specialist area is
that you're interested in
thank you so final question uh brendan
what's the best way to get
i see your twitter handle and your
linkedin on the
site but what's the best ways to get in
touch with you for anyone watching this
or recording of this and wants to ask
some questions and what's the best way
to get involved with deepsea
yeah sure um there is actually one link
that i forgot to send here
which is our slack channel we have a
slack channel i
should really have said that earlier um
because we have we see a lot of really
cool
activity there from people who are just
working with it who want to ask basic
questions
who want to just i don't even kind of
just get to know a little bit of what
we're working on
um so this is the link here um
just gonna actually add it once yeah we
can actually add it there
i would really encourage you to um get
in touch via
buy slack but you can also find me on
linkedin on twitter
uh but slack is where where we have this
community of other people who are
actually also answering questions if
you're working with haystack
and you're not sure what like if you
need a little bit of help with the next
step
um you can ask there and we get onto
these questions as quickly as we can but
we also see that we've had a lot of
people in our community
who've been really willing to help out
with other people in the community and
that's actually a really nice
really nice to see it's really nice
feeling so if you want to get involved
i highly recommend that perfect any
other ways to get
involved with protests that you're doing
uh we're always
interested in um we're all like we
always uh
are very active on github so we're
constantly raising we have a road map
that shows what we're trying to
incorporate next
and we have um and yeah through our
issues and through our pr through prs
you can see what we're working on but
we're also very very open
to any community contributions if you
say hey uh
i don't know i i really like retrievers
let's let's create
this kind of a retriever let's integrate
this new retrieve with this cool
retriever that i found
uh suggest it to us talk talk to us
about it on
on on github open a pr we can guide you
we can help you out with uh
navigating the code i think it's a good
learning experience for anyone who's
trying to get some experience as well
and um yeah let's let's go from there
we're like we love to interact with
people through all these different
channels
and once again if you if you if you
think that these kind of the kinds of
problems that you're interested in
working in
um consider consider sending like
talking us to
about a job application where like it's
really cool actually that people are
just asking this and wanting to get
involved we
we really love getting other people
excited about nlp as well
perfect thank you so so much brandon for
talking to us and thank you for
doing this important work yes and um i'm
just i just posted the link to wonder
where we'll do postdoc mingling in this
2d
platform where you can uh talk in groups
and get to know each other
and uh i'll see you there and in pi data
next month
thank you so much yeah i just want to
say thanks again and i'll be in wonder
in just a minute and uh yeah thanks very
much
perfect we'll yeah we will post a link
to the slides and some of the other
links in the meetup notes
at least on youtube as well yeah
can maybe brandon you can also put the
link to the slide
on the meetup absolutely yeah
uh yes we'll do great thank you thank
you everyone
see you everyone thank you if you want
i let the people leave i don't want to
kick them out